[Applaudissements]
donc si on peut éviter de
cacher mais franchement me retrouver ici
à la télé c'est je trouve ça aussi
surréaliste que Bachar el-Assad qui
reçoit le prix Nobel donc je suis pas là
pour critiquer la télé je trouve ça
vachement utile comme un des seuls
endroits où se rencontrent l'élite et
les chômeurs
merci de faire l'élite en tout cas ce
soir quand même 41300 chômeurs de plus
en un mois
chômeur métier d'avenir
en même temps ces chiffres seraient
beaucoup plus faible si les nouveaux
chômeurs avaient la pudeur de pas le
faire savoir
c'est quand même dingue ce mal français
se vantait de son inactivité
l'arrogance des chômeurs
j'étais venu pourquoi déjà ah oui donc
je disais Thierry ton truc s'appelle
Salut les Terriens moi je vois pas trop
rêver à ce que tu leur trouves enfin
est-ce qu'ils ont si génial à des formes
je suis pas tout ça enfin les martiens
je trouve ça beaucoup plus intelligent
tu vois ils cherchent pas à nous
connaître
le prof d'un génie quoi d'ailleurs ça
pouvait continuer ça serait bien nous
pour se faire remarquer qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on lance des sons dans l'espace
avec de la musique de Mozart enfin ce
n'est aucun intérêt quoi franchement on
devrait plutôt envoyer ça
vous savez ce que c'est
émeute dans ta chatte
ouais
si on soit disant les rebelles de l'été
qu'elle arnaque si elles étaient si
rebelles que ça ils auraient fait la
Macarena dans une mosquée
ils ont pris deux ans de goulag 2 ans de
boulot la preuve que Poutine s'assouplit
quoi
[Musique]
le goulag on trouve l'inspiration au
goût génity n'était pas allé au goulag
il aurait écrit quoi
l'archipel de ma cuisine
donc amis martien surtout restez chez
vous ne venez pas parce que ici ça n'a
aucun intérêt quoi je veux dire
politiquement c'est dur c'est dur
la gauche c'est au pouvoir
les bolcheviks sont passés
depuis que la gauche est passée quoi moi
je me promène jamais tout seul toujours
avec une femme c'est la parité
puis que la gauche est passé cette femme
elle peut pas être de ma couleur quoi ça
s'appelle la diversité
c'est pas le seul effet l'arrivée de la
gauche ça fait fuir les riches exemple
Stéphane Guillon
après je suis pas là pour dézinguer la
gauche le président enfin c'est un mec
c'est René Coty Jr
autocollant j'aime la Plagne quoi
il a pris un break parce qu'un
corbillard c'était un peu trop tôt
encore c'est le truc qui va arriver quoi
on lui reproche de pas avoir le même
rythme que Sarko qu'elle est génique à
Sarko quand même
je veux dire
non mais c'est comme incroyable ce type
qui arrive à convaincre les Français que
l'hystérie c'est un truc rassurant quoi
je comprends pour les Français c'est pas
facile quoi passer d'un coup de 24
heures chrono à Louis la Brocante
heureusement qu'il est en couple avec
une fille un peu tendue parce que pas le
couple Hollande privé l'air ça me fait
penser à une éponge de cuisine tu vois
un côté qui gratte l'autre qui absorbe
[Musique]
alors
il paraît que vous vous y êtes pour
quelque chose vous avez de réouvrir un
site de rencontre quoi c'est à chaque
fois
non mais en tout cas on s'attendait à
tout avec Hollande sauf au feu de
l'amour quoi c'est le truc vraiment et
qu'est-ce que lui trouve à Hollande
c'est quoi son déjà il y a des rumeurs
il paraît qu'il a un côté reptilien
dragueur comme ça j'ai une copine elle a
pris l'ascenseur avec lui c'est ce qu'il
a fait rien
DSK il a vu ça il se dit [ __ ] ce mec
c'est un fou tu vois
alors vous me direz l'opposition existe
team Fillon contre team Copé la France
coule il joue interview quoi c'est le
truc mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tous à
l'UMP de se réclamer de Sarkozy je
comprends pas il est mort
fassiez tellement génial faut le
rappeler quoi je sais pas et non vas-y
Rachid
mais tout ça c'est de l'anecdote ça
c'est du microcosme c'est de la petite
tambouille ça c'est pas nous il y a des
choses beaucoup plus graves en France
beaucoup plus grave
Audrey Pulvar gère les Inrock
t'imagines c'est comme Christine Boutin
chez Playboy
playmate du mois Bernadette Soubirou en
string
un rêve de gosse
puis à la sécurité bon ça c'est réglé
maintenant c'est un souci il y a Manuel
Valls Sarko qui s'habille chez Zara tu
vois le truc
bah il y a pas de miracle il y a moins
de fric à gauche les gens ils font un
peu moins des fois ils peuvent pas quoi
faire Rachida vous êtes une Fadela
amarachique quoi il y a un truc
il y a toutes ces polémiques sur les
Roms tout ça ça va quoi ça ça pour des
gens du voyage que de chichi à l'idée
d'un déplacement
économiquement c'est dur quoi c'est la
crise c'est la crise est tellement forte
que même des braqueurs s'attaquent à
Emmaüs tu imagines la réunion
préparatoire des gars demain on se fait
quoi ce cours populaire le Resto du
Coeur ah non pas les restos j'ai assez
de boîtes de cassoulet quoi faut faire
autre chose
c'est un problème
la France dépense mal son argent c'est
une évidence
bon on n'est pas les seuls le Qatar
investit bien dans le PSG
c'est comme un gagnant de l'euromillion
lui dit alors vous allez faire quoi de
votre argent ah moi je vais acheter de
la dette grecque quoi tu vois
toute façon moi le sport je pourra je
dis me taper les Jeux Olympiques il y
avait rien d'autre alors il y a des
jolies images je peux pas dénigrer c'est
le truc Manaudou et son frère
[ __ ] moi l'inceste ça m'a toujours
bah ici on a qui aiment pas fait autre
chose quoi ça sert à rien
évidemment après le jeux olympiques on
doit se taper les paralympiques quel
régal
cours des miracles fait de l'EPS
concours Lépine de la béquille
orthopédique enfin je sais pas qui
regarde ça
de toute façon il y a un problème de
calendrier quoi les Jeux Olympiques et
après les paralympiques
c'est comme voir une course de caisse à
savon après une course de Formule 1
mais il y a des nouvelles rassurantes
Johnny est vivant
parce que lui c'est un rocker c'est un
iconoclaste c'est un mec choper une
bronchite à Saint-Barth quoi
la malaria au Pôle Nord
comme un puceau qui décède de la
syphilis quoi c'est pareil
mais bon peut-être finir sur une
nouvelle un peu optimiste quand on est
positif prix de l'essence baisse
pas belle la vie
[Musique]
bon allez beaucoup pensent que depuis la
dernière fois les choses ont changé ah
oui radicalement vous avez vu dimanche
soir l'intervention moi je suis l'air
François lève le pied tout de suite
quand on a un airbag qui s'appelle
Jean-Marc Ayrault
le but de l'airbag c'est qui gonfle pas
l'inverse quoi
non
président héro Premier ministre Harlem
Désir premier secrétaire quand même
désir qui a été élu je respecte je veux
dire l'inventeur du pin's pour myope tu
sais le truc
moi j'ai longtemps pensé que la grosse
main d'un Dingo là c'était comme pour le
ruban rouge du sida tu vois sauf que
c'était pour l'hépatite
heureusement en tout cas qui s'appelle
Harlem Désir quoi moi ça c'est un prénom
qui cogne quoi c'est pas c'est pas l'UMP
vous avez pas ça quand vous avez pas un
mec qui s'appelle Neuilly blasé
mais ça ça c'est de la petite cuisine
j'ai mal au pratique ça c'est
intéressant honnêtement ce qui compte
c'est qu'on arrête de l'ennuyer il faut
arrêter de l'ennuyer quoi si à chaque
fois qu'ils s'énerve il crée un impôt
enfin moi je peux pas
braque l'État va gagner 30 milliards
impressionnant j'espère qu'il va
s'appliquer les 75% pour voir comme ça
fait mal
en tout cas moi je suis content que les
75% concernent les artistes vraiment je
trouve ça comme ça les jours où j'ai pas
d'inspiration au travail je me dis waouh
je fais au moins chier le fisc mais
attention il a de grandes ambitions ça
je veux pas juger inverser la courbe du
chômage en un an sans croissance
au moins on tient une info solide quoi
allez lisez les salles de shoot
fonctionne à plein tube
[Applaudissements]
on a tout essayé pour l'emploi ça on l'a
tout essayé relancé l'emploi relancer la
croissance diminuer les impôts augmenter
les impôts enfin il reste quoi enfin par
trucider les chômeurs moi je vois pas
trop le tueur ou les pousser à
l'expatriation ça leur fera un réflexe
de riche au moins un truc en commun
tu vas partir en Belgique non pas en
fait Bucarest c'est
je me demande est-ce qu'il y a dans le
métro de Bucarest des mendiants français
qui interprète des tubes en roumain
[Applaudissements]
on a pas beaucoup d'imagination
franchement j'ai vu que Xavier Bertrand
propose une candidature générationnelle
NKM est le maire quelque chose comme
attelage
la polytechienne le normalien et l'agent
d'assurance
dirait un film de Sergio Leone
la matteuse de littéraire et l'escroc
[Applaudissements]
quant à vous Besançon moi je ferais
moins le malin anticapé ah ouais ouais
un type qui a au moins une fois dans sa
vie distribué une enveloppe à bétoncourt
qu'est-ce que va prendre la pauvre
qu'est-ce que va prendre une rentière
mais bon c'est quoi un rentier c'est
quoi un rentier c'est un chômeur qui a
l'élégance de pas demander une
allocation
Arnaud va partir en Belgique alors tout
le monde qui couine ah ouais mais
Bernard Arnault est parti en Belgique
pour des raisons financières
heureusement on va partir pour le climat
[Applaudissements]
ou les paysages quoi les paysages belges
le paysage belge
enfin le jour où la terre se désintègre
si elle a un masque mortuaire c'est la
Belgique
tu m'étonnes que Napoléon ait perdu à
Waterloo il est arrivé là-bas il a vu le
truc j'ai dit ah non j'ai pas envie de
me battre
faire la guerre avec la chanson de Abba
dans la tête tout le temps c'est pas
mais je me disais quand on pense que
l'homme le plus riche de France doit
s'exiler en Belgique alors que des
retraités à peine smicard s'expatrie au
Maroc
où est la logique quoi Olivier
explique-moi bah ouais et Bernard et
fragile Bernard est fragile porter
plainte
au lieu de porter plainte tu l'aurais
mieux fait de racheter l'idée
avec une éditoriale un peu sévère comme
ça pour faire chier les gauchistes qui
bossent là-bas un truc qui ferait passer
le Figaro pour un journal anarchiste
t'imagines la première une la photo de
Copé
avec le titre peut-on faire confiance à
un mot
ça c'est
ce que vous oubliez Besançon qui sont
les clients de LVMH ok les riches
vous croyez vraiment que la caissière de
Monoprix là les moyens de la chimie
balle dans un cul de votre année
alors on veut mettre à la porte un type
qui fonctionne les risques comme
incroyable quoi au lieu de stigmatiser
ce pauvre homme quoi il faut se
renseigner un peu moi j'ai vu chiffre
d'affaires de levmh 20 milliards par an
20 milliards qui prend ou 90% à
l'international
donc il prend chez les riches en plus
étranger si c'est pas un patriote je
sais pas
non Arnaud c'est quand même le
dalaï-lama du sakapu
pendant ce temps Hollande joue au curé
économique enfin forcément à force de
visiter les usines pour dire désolé on
peut rien faire c'est devenu c'est une
sorte de donneur de dernier sacrement
industriel
mon bon ouvrier confesse tes péchés
avant d'aller au chômage
heureusement qu'il y a des techniques
pour faire oublier qu'on peut rien faire
des réformes dont tout le monde se fout
en ce moment si tu bosses chez PSA le
seul gens qui ont un peu d'espoir c'est
les homos avec un projet de mariage
je disais au prochain plan social il va
proposer quoi ça va être quoi le gimmick
la possibilité pour les enfants
d'adopter les parents le droit opposable
au cancer
le classement du Vélib' comme espèce
protégée
faut finir avec un truc un peu
sympathique une bonne nouvelle DSK porte
plainte aussi
je comprends t'imagines trois
couvertures avec la même femme
attends tu as la réputation polygame
quoi
alors pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
bon allez semaine numéro 3 j'espère
juste que tu t'entends pas à ce que je
parle des excroissances mammaires de
Kate Middleton
non parce que moi je connais un bon
dermato en trois secondes il t'enlève ça
quoi
par où commencer ah ouais tu savais toi
que les musulmans étaient obligés de
d'acheter Charlie Hebdo non alors tout
ce cirque sur les dessins du prophète
dans la mesure où personne ne l'a jamais
vu qu'est-ce qui nous dit que Charlie
est forcément dans la caricature
non ça l'affiche il faut pas déconner
c'est quoi c'est un type qui est juste
pas assez doué pour faire dealer quoi
[Rires]
attention je dis ça je suis pas là pour
critiquer les dealers
à samedi soir à 3h du matin c'est
peut-être les seuls mecs qui sont sobre
et moi je comprends leur malaise je
comprends leur malaise les pauvres tu
vois ils sont manifestés plein huitièmes
arrondissement entouré de boutique pour
poufiasse des petites femmes qui
déambule et dont les plus pudiques sont
à peine recouvertes d'un képi
non franchement lâcher un salafiste en
Occident ça va être aussi angoissant que
parachuter un boulimique au four quoi
c'est un peu
en tout cas moi quand je vois la
débauche d'énergie que mettent les
salafistes pour faire la promo d'un film
qui déteste qu'est-ce qui nous aurait
cassé les couilles s'il l'avait aimé
non mais ça a fait beaucoup réagir cette
histoire de film tout ça alors
l'attentat le plus violent a eu lieu à
Kaboul
au moins une bonne nouvelle quoi on
Afghanistan ils sont la fibre optique
pays pauvre mais connecté quoi
de toute façon vous savez que les
États-Unis vont bientôt réagir quoi
Obama a pris des mesures de rétorsion il
sorte une version en Blu-ray
alors évidemment des gens qui sont en
couple dans la brèche pour en parler tu
as enfin Véronique Genest tout de suite
j'avais envie que jeunesse tu vois
Zemmour après un AVC quoi c'est le truc
alors elle a dit qu'elle a lu le Coran
ça aurait TF1 repère d'intello quoi
alors on se dit que le FN va récupérer
bah évidemment mais le FN comment dire
c'est un parti bon le FN pour moi est
aux électeurs parce que la voiture
brûlée est au voyou quoi ça sert à rien
mais ça défoule
non mais
géographiquement je suis pas je suis pas
partiel je veux dire géographiquement
c'est intéressant le vote Eiffel
concerne surtout le Vaucluse et le gars
l'ancienne zone libre quoi
je dis ça je dis rien attention je suis
pas là on a beaucoup entendu Marine Le
Pen alors les députés vous avez élus des
députés mais
c'est à croire que pour qu'il la boucle
il suffit de les élire quoi c'est genre
il y a plus personne quoi toute façon si
le danger c'est les deux élus que vous
avez enfin je veux pas
non mais Gilbert Collard et Marion
maréchal quoi enfin le Vergès du pauvre
et la pom-pom girl de la garrigue c'est
pas
non mais au moins vous êtes perspicace
hein franchement vous avez tout de suite
compris qu'avec le nombre de vieux
dégueulasses qui a l'Assemblée il faut
mettre une protection juridique pour la
petite quoi c'est
[Applaudissements]
elle parle comme une déléguée de la
classe
va arriver là mais ça trousse Hello
Kitty enfin je veux dire c'est alors
Marion on t'en pense quoi de la CSG ah
moi je suis con sauf en cas de viol
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sortez de la bien-pensance
plus graves des choses beaucoup plus
graves pendant ce temps qu'est-ce qu'il
fait notre Kim Jong-il national
s'enflamme sur le gaz de schiste c'est
vraiment l'extraterrestre ce mec Jacques
Chirac la fracture géologique quoi
alors la droite en face l'UMP il cherche
leur petit mal dominant tu vois ce
serait mieux de résoudre le truc à la
loyal tu vois sur le Champ de Mars à
combat de boxe entre Copé Fillon le
chariothèque des kermesse contre la
béquille du 7e tu vois le truc
cette préoccupation de la présidentielle
moi je comprends pas cette obsession
d'être président enfin Président c'est
quand même un des rares postes ou tu es
sûr qu'une fois élu tu seras un
populaire
tu m'étonnes que vous aviez Bertrand se
précipite
évidemment on essaie de faire diversion
on essaie de faire ça c'est le grand
truc l'anniversaire après le mariage gay
le droit de vote des étrangers
donc contrairement à ce que j'ai dit la
semaine passée en ce moment chez PSA les
seuls qui ont de l'espoir ce sont les
ouvriers homo qui ont un projet de
mariage et dont l'un des conjoints est
un extra-communautaire qui rêve délire
un conseiller municipal
je sens que ça va se bousculer au
portillon on peut aller mecs vont être
de toute façon cette histoire de mariage
ça continue de faire polémique blabla
Barbara là le l'archevêque qui a déclaré
que le mariage gay c'était la porte
ouverte à l'inceste et à la polygamie
c'est plutôt un argument pour
et se taper sa mère c'est quand même une
des rares opportunités de prendre du
recul avec l'endroit d'où l'on vient
peut-être qu'elle était pas efficace au
pied avec vous quoi j'en sais rien
alors évidemment l'église est vachement
opposée super réac l'église elle
s'oppose au mariage tout ça parce que
deux homosexuels n'arrivent pas à se
reproduire
laissez-leur un peu de temps
quel manque de confiance dans la théorie
de l'évolution naturelle
bon je fais un peu moins le malin
aujourd'hui parce que je suis
impressionné il y a un prof parmi nous
quoi c'est
j'ai entendu il y a des rumeurs sur les
profs quoi c'est c'est vrai que vous
devez passer 5 jours par semaine 6
heures par jour avec des gosses
et vous n'avez pas le droit d'en tuer un
pour l'exemple
et là
alors quoi d'autre bon le week-end
dernier on avait le choix entre la Fête
de l'Huma où les journées du patrimoine
évidemment je suis au lit aujourd'hui du
patrimoine tu me connais la Fête de
l'Huma moi je peux pas quoi c'est quand
même le seul festival ou entre deux
morceaux de rock et un gros lourd qui
vient de parler du traité de Maastricht
quoi
une bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle à
Bernard Tapie là qui a acheté une maison
à 45 millions je trouve ça bien enfin un
homme politique qui a réussi sur
magouille
alors elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez ça va ça va bon
économiquement Florange tu es vivement
que ça ferme enfin qu'ils arrêtent un
peu avec leurs besoins permanents de
faire fondre de l'acier c'est quand même
dingue mais genre 2012 il y a des gens
qui ont la nostalgie des boulots du 19e
siècle franchement l'ex minital c'est un
humaniste qui a envie de travailler
aujourd'hui avec un casque de chantier 8
heures par jour devant un four à 1000
degrés dans une odeur d'acier gris et
quoi
que les gars de Florent ils se
masturbent en lisant germinal toi la
psychologie des mecs le week-end ils
font quoi des barbecues à sec juste pour
évoquer le boulot
moi je préfère être au chômage très
honnêtement quoi c'est pas sport cette
histoire de handballeur c'est assez
tragique c'est normal c'était inventé en
Allemagne de l'Est
tu vois que le truc le plus joyeux qui
vient d'Allemagne de l'Est c'est Merkel
on a de la marge
tu as un handballeur en fait c'est quoi
c'est le mec qui est pas assez doué des
pieds pour faire footballeur pas assez
viril pour jouer au rugby mais assez con
quand même pour jouer au ballon
[Applaudissements]
alors
l'histoire des paris c'est quand même le
casse du siècle d'habitude sur un pari
pour Montpellier c'est 3000 euros en
moyenne là ils ont mis 70 000 puis comme
si c'était pas assez discret dit ouais
ma copine qui travaille à la télé va
acheter les billets quoi pour la fille
il travaille à la télé douce
c'est pas la télé c'est une radio avec
une webcam quoi
[Applaudissements]
parce que tout et tout ça pourquoi tout
pour gagner 250 000 euros alors ok à 19
tu vois c'est quoi l'idée c'est acheter
une Ferrari en copropriété le truc faire
du covoiturage
c'est triste quoi les footballeurs ils
voient ça ils jettent une pièce
d'ailleurs je me demande vu que l'équipe
de Montpellier est décimée est-ce qu'ils
ont été assez intelligents pour parier
sur les défaites futurs
tu as vu le Gaspard prose l'humour
intelligent enfin bref
alors il paraît que Guéno a dit que tout
était truqué dans la course au
parrainage
c'est pas moi
vous avez parié combien sur des fêtes de
Copé
[Rires]
il prend tout le temps moi franchement
Copé tout le temps cette polémique là
sur le racisme anti-blanc enfin c'est
purement à l'extéralisme en France il y
a plus de blanc que noir il va pas
défendre les poux rouges quoi il est
moi moi je sors un vrai racisme anti
blanc quoi enfin moi avec ma tronche je
me fais jamais contrôler
façon le contrôle officiel ça n'existe
pas c'est une rumeur ça c'est pas si les
jeunes des cités se font interpeller
quatre fois par jour c'est juste parce
qu'ils ont des noms plus compliqués à
retenir
façon politiquement ça avance Taubira
veut fermer des prisons c'est quand même
con avec l'école c'est le seul endroit
qui fixe des limites au gamin
elle veut proposer des peines de
substitution à la prison il faut qu'on
m'explique c'est quoi une peine de
substitution à la prison
un patch qui diffuse une odeur de maton
[Applaudissements]
je comprends que les jeunes soient
déboussolés après des drames à regarder
bon strabisme grande cause nationale
je me disais la Joconde avec son sourire
un peu énigmatique tu vois le déambule
dans les faubourgs de Grenoble elle fait
pas 100 mètres c'est la tournant
alors attention il y a quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de tout René Coty là
il est boosté là il revient de l'ONU il
sent plus quoi c'est le mec tu vois il a
regardé qui moule ah on peut être moins
charismatique c'est le truc dans le quoi
[Rires]
non mais tu l'as vu la Grenoble sous la
fenêtre faire son imitation de Sarko
quoi c'est vraiment
mauvaise chansonnier quoi tu vois
l'autre qui l'alpaque façon livreuse
d'encornet à Rungis là ouais on a voté
pour vous
il y a déjà le droit de vote des
étrangers ah pardon madame
alors lui il répond sécurité justice
réussite
c'est pas Jean-Michel Apathie au balcon
mais le mec il sort ses fiches de l'ENA
pour parler aux poissonnière tu dis
attends on prend des cours chez Morano
un peu
ça c'est pour toi voilà je savais
alors le discours de vérité en banlieue
c'est qu'il faut dire qu'il y a pas
d'avenir madame franchement déjà avec
bac + 5 les gens ira vous imaginez un
brevet des collèges obtenu la Courneuve
il fait quoi les gars
la preuve il est là
il fallait être plus viril quoi tu vois
genre tu les tiens un peu pardon
et si c'est le Texas monsieur
ils ont la peine
[Rires]
international alors j'ai appris qu'ils
avaient retiré les femmes dans le
catalogue IKEA d'Arabie Saoudite ça
c'est une erreur d'impression
porte atteinte à l'image de la femme
saoudienne ils ont pas affiché le prix
de la femme
quoi d'autre
géopolitique les otages au Mali c'est
quand même malheureux arrivé à se faire
kidnapper dans un désert
t'imagines la poisse quoi j'aimerais pas
être assis à côté du mec dans l'avion
quoi parti un peu ludique Salon de
l'Auto c'est important l'automobile ça
permet de conserver un levier de
croissance c'est un truc parce que ça
relance l'économie on connaît la
solution on dit que oui pour faire de
l'emploi et relancer c'est pas le coup
du travail le problème ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que les constructeurs français
soient capables de concurrencer Mercedes
imagine le nouveau riche brésilien
devant son Arras sa piscine son jet
privé tu vois il se dit ah il manque un
truc dans ma vie une Kangoo alors
[Applaudissements]
pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as remarqué le bouddhisme ça prend
pas dans les prisons non c'est vrai et
oui cette semaine encore on a découvert
en banlieue une cellule dormante de
chrétiens fanatique qui agressaient des
habitants dans les cages d'escalier en
leur tendant à tour de rôle leur joue
droite puis leur joue gauche
il faut que cela cesse que le climat
s'appelle et que les communautés
retournent sur lyncher entre elles
non alors pas une semaine sans que
l'islamisme ne fasse la une la dernière
fois j'allume ma télé tu vois je tombe
sur un imam fou en train de prêcher en
fait c'était Diam's
je veux pas la critiquer moi je la
préfère musulmane que rappeuse
alors le terroriste s'appelait Jérémy
Louis Sidney bon moi je veux le
comprendre le type avec un nom pareil il
vaut mieux se convertir et s'appelait
shérif à l'islam
à Louis Sidney moi ça me déstabilise
comme nom on sait pas si c'est un nom je
dis qui organise des rencontres de Tunis
ou un chanteur de zouk
comme d'habitude à tout ce cirque avec
l'interpellation alors la police qui est
choquée que le type les attendent avec
un flingue
c'est un terroriste
ils arrivent déguisés en Robocop et de
l'autre côté il s'attendent à quoi je
dire le mec qui va les attendre avec une
[ __ ] à mouche tu vois il ouvre la
porte il sert des loukous et du thé
normalement
aucune logique alors comme la famille du
gate qui porte plainte contre les flics
pour homicide volontaire
encore heureux que c'est volontaire si
même les flics se mettent à tirer au
hasard
le trucider sans faire exprès
je t'ai un filet de pêche
ou demander le carnet de correspondance
sur la tête forcément toute la réaction
des voisins le truc la réaction
habituelle ah non mais c'était quelqu'un
très gentil
c'était quelqu'un de très gentil en
général c'est comme ça commence toutes
les histoires dans Faites entrer
l'accusé
[Musique]
un mec tu es gentil les serviable il
nous disait bonjour
sans déconner
évidemment le gars il veut monter des
homicides au TNT il va les prévenir tout
le monde quoi dire ouais bonjour moi je
suis un fou furieux quand je déposter de
Ben Laden à la maison je vais tous vous
égorger mais surtout vous le dites pas
parce que sinon je suis dans la merde
tout ça pour faire quoi alors c'est ça
le plus dramatique tout ça pour faire
quoi jeter une bombe dans une épicerie
il y a pas que l'économie qui souffre
d'un manque de compétitivité le
terrorisme aussi
il paraît qu'il était pas tout seul
c'est vrai que quand on a autant
d'intelligence serait dommage pas la
partager
c'est tout un réseau tu es les mecs qui
cogit des mois ils échappent des plantes
tout ça pour [ __ ] en l'air une
superette
c'est je suis désolé c'est un manque
d'intégration
encore en une nuit de font péter une
dizaine de centres Leclerc sans faire à
mort
voilà et voilà et voilà
[Applaudissements]
on peut dire ce qu'on veut mais l'écorce
il bouffent peut-être du porc mais au
moins ils sont efficaces
alors évidemment les convertis sont les
plus radicaux ça c'est normal moi je
connais un ami qui était musulman et
c'est converti au christianisme
à force d'aller à la messe il est devenu
alcoolique c'est c'est comme les
comédiens qui se lancent ils en font
toujours trop tu vois pour les castings
j'existe puis après ils font plus belle
la vie
et je vous parle pas de ceux qui
finissent pitre dans des talk shows
genre Canal+ c'est la honte absolue
alors évidemment chacun réagit président
du CRIF
l'islamisme c'est le nouveau nazisme
ça ferait bien de revoir c'est classique
pour un juif au 21e siècle ne pas
distinguer le nazisme
non mais c'est pas la même chose les
nazis ils avaient Wagner les islamistes
ils ont diables quoi tu vois le truc
[Applaudissements]
islamisme la nazisme les mille et une
nuits de cristal enfin bon
politique faut quand même en parler un
peu couverture du point DSK parle
parce que moi je pensais que lui faisait
que
c'est bizarre ce mec
heureusement que d'autres sont là pour
prendre la relève alors j'ai vu la Une
de L'Express
ces femmes qui gâchent la vie quoi c'est
socialiste et Don Juan quoi
international merci quelle partie en
Grèce en ce moment dramatique les
Allemands n'ont plus d'argent si même la
chancelière est obligé de partir là-bas
hors saison
tu as vu l'accueil de fou moi je
comprends qu'elle se fasse siffler les
tips ils sont à fond ils ont sorti les
drapeaux à croix gammées tu as une nana
de la Cedeo qui débarque que les mecs
sont déçus quoi ils s'attendaient un
truc plus un peu plus viril quoi tu vois
ce que je veux dire quoi bon
fait divers alors je peux pas parler de
faits divers sans parler de Marseille
corruption à la BAC on en parle beaucoup
on parle beaucoup trop trop travailler à
la BAC c'est peut-être une des rares
occasions pour un flic d'être associé à
un diplôme
alors à Marseille ils ont découvert une
nana qui avait une crèche clandestine ça
c'est toute la différence entre les
Chinois et les Français quoi les Chinois
quand ils travaillent au black ils
ouvrent une entreprise les Français un
service public
et alors est-ce qu'il y a aussi des
bonnes nouvelles c'est dur à trouver là
il y a cette photo d'un acteur porno gay
qui pose devant Auschwitz je vous
souhaite bonne chance pour monter son
dossier d'adoption
[Applaudissements]
alors elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
alors forcément cette semaine la grande
nouvelle c'est le type qui bat des
records de chute déjà c'est un
Autrichien pas la première fois qu'un
autre chien explose un compteur
c'est quand même dingue les gens ils
sont fascinés parce qu'un pauvre type
saute sur Terre on habite cosmonaute
quoi c'est le truc si on a marché sur la
terre quoi quelqu'un lui a dit qu'il y
avait de l'oxygène sur la planète enfin
je n'arrive manquer plus que ah je crois
qu'il y a des traces d'eau il était bon
pour le rayon psychiatrique Sainte-Anne
franchement c'était quoi ce machin
lancement de la FIAC et vraiment des
gens qui ont rien à faire quoi l'autre
qui fanfaronnes perché dans un testicule
accroché un ballon mollement gonflé on
aurait dit le vrai portrait de François
Hollande
alors ok ok alors après d'accord c'est
le 1er mec qui a passé le mur du son de
l'altitude de laquelle il a sauté même
une chèvre elle l'aurait passée
d'ailleurs cette semaine il était pas le
seul héros aussi à passer le mur du son
il devait vraiment aller vite parce que
sa parole a mis 5 mois arrivée donc pour
dire quoi pour recadrer payant alors ça
c'est un vrai exploit arrivé à se faire
recadrer par du vide quoi
héros calcule au déclaré oh je ne suis
pas Premier ministre par hasard
merci de nous prévenir on n'était pas au
courant
ça c'est sûr qu'il est pas là par hasard
c'est quand même grâce à lui qu'on
arrive à croire au charisme d'Hollande
toute façon moi je comprends payant on
donne souvent du shit aux gens en soins
palliatifs c'est normal qu'on enfile à
l'éducation nationale
dans les classes ça va être bien c'est
avant les cours 15 minutes de fumette
obligatoire pour tout le monde ah ça va
être vachement plus détendu tu vois puis
les profs ils ont un vrai moyen de
réprimer les élèves non arrête de faire
le con sinon j'achète plus chez toi quoi
[Musique]
toute façon il y a que la sanction
économique qui marche ça on le sait bien
puis faut dire le trafic de drogue c'est
quand même le seul moyen pour des jeunes
issus de milieu défavorisés de
rencontrer des gens haut placé c'est
vrai ah vous êtes dans
d'accords des procureurs enfin des juges
après ça dépend de la drogue que tu
dises si c'est de la coque tu rencontres
des gens de pouvoir si tu dis le sud tu
rencontres qui des écolos
d'ailleurs cette semaine enfin une écolo
glamour merci merci de mettre un peu de
vie quoi ça nous change d'Éva jolie
le polpote de la biomasse moi c'est bon
encore un moment
alors c'est pas tout on a découvert un
truc il paraît qu'il est vend des
sextoys écolo
alors bon moi j'ai regardé en tant que
journaliste que je ne suis pas qu'est-ce
que c'est un sextoy color c'est des
canards sans talent
sur la sexualité des écolos
chez eux les canards et les font pas
vibrer il est macho
avec l'ego de Michel ils font quoi
exclure les oreilles avec
ça c'est très très inquiétant après la
panoplie alors j'ai lu
lubrifiant anal à l'extrait naturel
d'écorce de goyave waouh elle vend ça
aussi lingerie bio alors je passe avec
le string en chambre c'est le machin
il manque plus que les boules de geisha
fournies avec un récipient en
Compostelle
délicatesse dans ce monde de brut
international aucun rapport la Corse
bon Marseille mais en version bucolique
quand même plus jolie
ou dès que tu as une maison tu es
persuadé que Colona est innocent
mais bon encore c'est un pays où on
prend tout au pied de la lettre c'est
vrai la preuve chez eux il y a une vraie
saison morte
[Rires]
15 morts depuis le début de l'année
c'est pas non plus je veux dire en Syrie
quand il y a 15 morts par jour les gens
ils disent ah ils sont en train de
s'arranger
bon évidemment tout le monde s'en fout
de la série a raison encore un pays qui
a mal choisi ses voisins je suis désolé
quand tu es d'accord d'être entouré par
la Turquie Israël le Liban l'Irak et
l'Iran enfin c'est que tu aimes avoir
des problèmes quoi
à propos de voyage la Syrie se doit vous
parler vous Lopez le voyageiste nature
est découverte
de la star en mal d'altruisme
ethnologique
en tout cas votre émission prouve un
truc c'est que il n'y a pas de star dans
les pays pauvres parce que la version
retour n'existe pas quoi
et je me suis demandé pourquoi vous
emmener toujours les gens chez des
pauvres
il y a personne qui a réussi dans les
pays que vous fréquentez
ça c'est juste voilà après non mais moi
vous m'emmenez un jour je sais pas en
Corée du Nord je préférais aller chez
dignitaire du régime que chez le chez le
paysan affamé quoi je veux dire ou chez
Kim Jong tu vois il paraît qu'il a une
cave superbe
pétrusion en contemplant une statue de
Lénine ça doit être une volupté qui vous
dépasse
sinon dans les infos un peu annexes bon
il y a les [ __ ] qui défilent à ex pas
les [ __ ] c'est elle qui s'appelle
comme ça slot work c'est un mouvement
qui dit ma jupe courte n'est pas une
invitation quand on voit les photos je
peux dire que le reste non plus
sinon sport le Japon a battu la France
mais la France a fait match nul contre
l'Espagne super c'est complètement
surréaliste quoi c'est qui qui les
entraîne c'est Salvador Dali André
Breton
la prochaine étape c'est quoi mettre 5
buts au Brésil et en prendre 22 des îles
Féroé
des bonnes nouvelles sinon cette semaine
alors il y a la black Fashion Week black
Fashion Week j'ai vu les photos que de
chemin parcouru depuis Tintin au Congo
et puis une bonne nouvelle l'Europe
vient de recevoir le prix Nobel de la
paix c'est à dire un truc jusque-là
réservé aux pays pauvres
ça a du bon le déclin
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parmi nous ce soir un philosophe ce qui
m'a inspiré un constat assez profond
enfin quand on voit la situation en
Grèce on se dit que c'est normal que ce
soit le pays qui a inventé la philo
bah oui quand on a pas les moyens de
s'en sortir autant avoir les outils pour
relativiser son échec
qu'est-ce que la philo le christianisme
des athées est-ce par Proust humoriste
haut de gamme on passe à la suivante
la fameuse photo d'Arnaud Montebourg a
fait la semaine alors moi j'ai pas très
bien compris quoi c'est quoi encore une
pub pour le mariage gay
on m'a expliqué que c'est censé
représenter la France qui réussissent
une marinière à mixeur
des vide-greniers du 11e arrondissement
alors ok il a une montre herbolin soit
disant de luxe sur une montre de luxe
avec un nom de camembert ou de biscotte
comme si les Allemands faisaient des
voitures haut de gamme avec des prénoms
de concierge espagnole
s'il voulait vraiment marquer le coup il
aurait mieux fait de poser en costume
Dior bottines Berluti dans un Rafale
avec une escalope de foie gras posé sur
la gauche alors heureusement que sa
copine porte des lunettes à 15000 euros
et on a au moins un pour rattraper
l'autre
toute façon politiquement il y a rien à
dire je veux dire Hollande impériale de
gouvernance héros incandescente charisme
Valls unique boulet du gouvernement
alors moi ça suffit le long de bashing
moi je vais pas le critiquer plus ça
passe plus je le trouve sympa quoi pour
une fois qu'il y a un type qui met un
peu de poésie dans la politique quand je
le vois il fait penser à un personnage
de Jacques Tati faisant du pédalo au
milieu du Cap Horn
il manque un truc sur le portrait
officiel du Président si c'est Magritte
qu'il avait fait il aurait écrit ceci
n'est pas un président
et puis et puis j'ai remarquéro pareil
quand enfin il a pris son autonomie quoi
plus besoin de ces ministres pour
cafouiller
c'est un génie poster Keaton du texte
législatif foutu d'avance et le type il
vient à la radio pour dire oh on a fait
un texte mais on passera pas quoi c'est
vraiment un humour quoi le type il a de
la peine à recadrer ses ministres il
annonce une opération pour pacifier la
Corse
le chef des logis Jean-Marc il lance
l'opération Tempête du maquis
résultat deux jours plus tard nouveau
mort sur l'île à mon avis le corps s'il
est mort de rire qu'on apprenant que ces
héros qui allait le cadre
alors ça ça ne s'est pas su c'est normal
c'est la tradition en Corse par honneur
on a criblé son corps de balle
encore une mort naturelle c'est jusqu'à
trois balles
entre 4 et 8 c'est un différent
économiques
au-delà de 8 c'est une bavure de chasse
c'est bon quand même au moins il y a un
truc dans ce gouvernement il y a du
désir il y a du désir Najat la
lobelcacem ah ouais non
[Musique]
comment résister à son aire d'écolière
ingénue qui semble dissimulé derrière
son pupitre des socquettes blanches à
pompon et sous sa jupe une culotte bio
c'est à dire rien
pour moi elle représente la synthèse
idéale de deux choses à priori
impossibles la volupté pédophile sans le
risque de l'âge
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
sur la prochaine fois que je la croise
moi j'attaque
alors ça se passe bien en CM2
viens chez moi on va faire un atelier
pâte à modeler pardon c'est un
gouvernement qui semble obsédé par le
cul mais sans rien y connaître
franchement ils ont cette idée de
rembourser la pilule dès 15 ans il y
avait une mesure beaucoup plus simple et
moins coûteux encourager la sodomie
les encouragez pas non mais la sodomie
c'est quand même un beau geste de mixité
sociale
la volupté du riche la contraception du
pauvre
et puis la gauche est faible évidemment
plus ça aiguise les appétits alors Borlo
a décidé de créer Ludy rien que le sigle
moi j'ai pas envie d'y aller enfin je
veux dire à côté OAS osto c'est plus
sexy
et quand tu vois les parages Giscard
Simone Veil on est en 2012 il
est en 2012 il convoque les 30
glorieuses enfin c'est qui qui va faire
la bande-son de clip de campagne
vladimir Cosma
un peu de compassion chrétienne même
vous Peltier franchement vous toute
façon si vous avez fait des conneries
enfin faut arrêter le rapport Merah qui
constate que la dcrie a sous-estimé le
risque c'est vrai quand on lit le
rapport il y avait pas de quoi
s'inquiéter
Russel d'armes goût pour les screams
frère salafiste visionnage de cassettes
d'exécution intérêt prononcé pour les
tribus pakistanaises voyage de six mois
en Afghanistan tu lis le rapport tu dis
ce mec c'est pas un terroriste c'est un
ethnologue
[Applaudissements]
de la cage d'escalier
triste tropique mais ça c'est sûr
pastoune
façon qu'on cesse les stigmatisations ça
c'est le grand mot le stigmatisation
Armstrong qui est le stigmatisé de la
semaine
alors c'est peut-être pas un exemple
pour les jeunes qui font du vélo mais
quel exemple pour les toxicomanes qui
n'en font pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà un homme qui prouve qu'on peut
être toxico gagner de l'argent avoir une
vie normale des enfants faire du sport
franchement à part lors des descentes de
police quand même rare de voir un
consommateur de crack faire du jogging
et moi j'ai vu des toxico en plus
mauvais état franchement Armstrong pour
un drogué tu mets dans une salle de
shoot tu le confonds avec le médecin de
garde
sinon ah oui les bonnes nouvelles de la
semaine Kerviel de rembourser 4,9
milliards
c'est facile lui la seule solution c'est
le mariage gay
à part ce Maquet avec Bernard Arnault je
vois pas trop de solutions pour lui
et puis des trucs plus ah ça c'est assez
un peu de respect ça c'est un peu
compliqué à 108 ans d'essai du doyen des
rescapés d'Auschwitz c'est avec ce genre
d'info que tu te rends compte que
finalement faire du sport et vous fait
bio ça sert à rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui j'ai oublié économiquement la
folie fiscale continue oui maintenant on
va taxer les boissons énergisantes c'est
cool vu la molette du gouvernement c'est
dans l'ordre des choses reste plus qu'à
défiscaliser la verveine
alors pas belle la vie
[Musique]
ça se prendra pas
j'y arriverai pas Guillaume non plus on
remarque
Guillaume à l'autre qui gagnait plus que
moi
de nombreux messages m'ont été adressés
suite à la dernière chronique dont un
très intéressant merci pour ce coup de
poignard au coeur que des milliers de
parents de victimes et de victimes de
pédophiles ont dû recevoir ce soir
devant votre édito à quand un édito sur
le viol collectif le lynchage raciste
les camps de concentration le massacre
des enfants en Syrie alors tu tenais à
remercier cette personne pour ces idées
de thème que je vous propose de
développer sans plus attendre
le lynchage raciste chaque jour en
France des gens mangent des pains au
chocolat
viol collectif ne vous verrons pas ce
terme d'un autre œil si on se contentait
de parler d'amour participatif
en ce qui concerne le massacre des
enfants en Syrie alors là c'est un petit
problème impossible de s'en moquer
puisque à l'heure où je vous parle on
peut se demander s'il reste encore des
enfants en Syrie
merci en tout cas pour ces idées en ce
qui concerne les comptes concentrations
c'est un sujet un peu plus délicat mais
on a trouvé une transition puisque
politiquement cette semaine on congrès
Toulouse Nisrine zaibi militante du PS a
déclaré à la tribune du Congrès qu'elle
avait la chance de pouvoir s'exprimer au
Congrès du Parti national socialiste
merci merci j'espère que désormais on
commencera enfin m'aborder dans la rue
en me traitant du Maurice de gauche
moi je ne voulais pas parler du PS cette
semaine parce que j'aime pas trop parler
des gens qui essaient de faire le même
métier que moi et qui arrive mieux
parce que là c'est vrai on tient on
tient une perle héros Jean-Marc vous
savez l'allemand avec un CAPES de
français
Steve est entrave exploser quoi
exceptionnel connaissez beaucoup de mecs
qui balancent une info le matin qui se
font recadrer par un ministre dans les 5
minutes et puis ce qui se regarde lui
même quatre fois dans la journée c'est
pas un amateur c'est ça génial ce mec
c'est
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs héros je me dis pourquoi être
sérieux et invisible quand il suffit de
dire des conneries pour exister
je ne sais pas qui est son conseiller
encore mais mais s'il en a il a dû se
faire les dents sur Eva jolie vraiment
domeney
toute façon je sens qu'on est parti pour
un moment là il a trouvé un créneau
évalué la semaine prochaine il va
revenir quoi sur les congés payés dans
deux mois ouais le retour au franc et
puis dans un an inch'Allah sera capable
de dire que l'Algérie française c'est
pas un tabou mais bon ça c'est normal
ces gens là ils découvrent le pouvoir ça
fait 11 ans qu'ils n'ont géré que des
régions autant dire pas grand chose
la seule décision visible que prend une
région c'est quoi remplacer un carrefour
par un rond-point j'espère vraiment que
quelqu'un a mis du scotch sur le bouton
nucléaire
pendant ce temps ce fameux duel que
passionne toute la France Copé Fillon
béret bleu contre bleu béret et on
dirait deux majorettes kimino des dons
la seule nuance se résume pour l'un à
dire ouais moi j'y vais Franco dans la
souillure et l'autre j'ai mes pudeur
mais ça me rend pas moins coquine
bref Copé qui veut organiser des manifs
pour déstabiliser le gouvernement
comme si ce gouvernement avait besoin
d'une manif pour être déstabilise
franchement quand on les voit on se dit
que même l'annonce du retour de la
croissance ce serait capable de les
faire paniquer
une manif de droite ça va être quelque
chose ça va [ __ ] les jetons ah ouais
ça c'est l'insoutenable flic flag des
mocassins et le hurlement au vent des
carrières mais
après la France qui gronde la France qui
froufroutent alors le tout dans le
grincement sardonique des poussettes
chargées de prénoms du 16e siècle les
Léopold les machins le truc alors
évidemment le cortège ira de terre à la
Muette avec un cocktail dînatoire place
du Trocadéro à la suite de quoi dans un
geste de protestation les manifestants
immoleront leur carte Club medjim
avec des slogans que nous allons tous
garder cheville au corps sous les pavés
Vinci garage
touche pas à ma mèche CRS et ss
heureusement
[Applaudissements]
non mais il ne faut pas désespérer si on
considère que beaucoup de 68 a ont fini
dans la pub et la finance qu'est-ce qui
nous dit que les chalalannes vont pas
finir dans l'éducation nationale et la
fonction publique
avec ces fameux heure en fin de cortège
pour disperser les manifestants les CRS
les ont aspergé d'une autre colonne
premier prix
soit il m'arrive de droite ça va pas
être bien méchant durant la fin il faut
faire quoi les racailles de nids des
magasins de cachemire voler des
chouquettes
économie le choc de la compétitivité
alors c'est les patrons qui couinent ah
non la chambre de compétitivité et alors
héros qui a eu cette jolie phrase
arrêtons dénigrer les chefs d'entreprise
car le mot entreprendre c'est un joli
mot
phonétiquement chômage c'est pas dégueu
non plus
on dirait un voyage sur le souci de la
valise perdu ou des contraintes horaires
quoi c'est pas c'est mon avis amour
parce qu'il faut bien parler de ça
misère sexuelle progresse en France et
oui en effet selon une étude du Parisien
un Français sur deux n'arrive pas à se
chauffer correctement
amour toujours Zahia prétend que Ribéry
n'est ni galant ni aimable ni gentil
quelqu'un lui a envoyé une fiche du
client avant d'y aller
s'attendait à quoi qu'il lui récite un
poème de Rimbaud en deux changements de
position qui lui mis une IVG sous
péridurale pour la faire marrer
arrête qui fasse du jonglage au ballon
comment une otarie à Marineland je sais
pas toute façon on choisit Ribéry pour
sa finesse à peu près aussi intelligente
d'accrocher une caravane camping à une
Bentley pour faire 24 Heures du Mans
[Applaudissements]
international Canal+ c'est la Semaine
USA ils disent pour faire un clin d'œil
OK
c'est bon on a ce qu'il faut
à Toulon il y a eu des inondations et un
pauvre garce est noyé c'est malheureux
quand on lui a remis une médaille
posthume du courage alors on cherche
encore le type qui n'a pas sauté pour
lui remettre la médaille vitale du
pragmatisme
société une fille qui vend pour 600.000
euros sa virginité pour faire des études
de médecine alors ce n'est qu'une
pénétration vaginale elle est prévoyante
elle se garde la nale en cas de
repêchage
[Applaudissements]
aucun rapport mais six mois avec sursis
pour une femme voilée
se pose alors cette question très
pratique si elle a un comportement
dangereux en prison comment faire pour
la mettre en cellule d'isolement
dans la vraie punition on serait quoi ça
serait de l'obliger à faire à moi de
naturisme au Cap d'Agde
là tu
mets
faut pas se désespérer ou pas non
vraiment il y a des bonnes nouvelles la
chancelière allemande inauguré un
mémorial au rhum mémorial conçu par
l'artiste Dany caravane
on dit que les clichés ont la vie dure
mais il est là
alors elle est pas belle la vie
bonsoir bonsoir ça va
soucieux de participer à la liesse qui
depuis mercredi envahit toutes les ondes
qui a fait se déplacer la moitié des
journalistes à l'autre bout de la terre
pour couvrir l'événement oui et dont les
résultats influencera de façon aussi
considérable nos vies que le calcul
rénal de François Fillon je joins ma
joie au concert d'enthousiasme vive
exigible nouveau président chinois
[Musique]
béni soit tu gloire à toi cher leader
communiste qui chaque jour nous rappelle
que le capitalisme se porte aussi bien
sans démocratie que le socialisme se
porte mal sans Manuel Valls
merci aussi à ce beau pays de me fournir
cette anecdote charmante de cette petite
fille de 4 ans défigurée par des
vêtements made in China
alors des vêtements qui ont été traités
si forts contre les moisissures qui lui
ont causé une allergie très sévère sont
vraiment trop forts et chinois
ils arrivent à creuser en même temps
l'autre balance commerciale et notre
trou de la Sécu
culturellement alors c'est la semaine
des prix littéraires avec cette sortie
fracassante le bouquin que tout le monde
a lu le rapport sur la compétitivité
alors je l'ai lu je l'ai lu ce qui
propose n'est pas très nouveau c'est les
classiques quoi la réorientation de
l'industrie vers l'armement la création
d'une voiture du peuple s'ouvrir vers
l'espace vital à l'Est
ah non pardon je confond avec un autre
truc
je confonds avec le rapport qui a permis
de lancer les 30 glorieuses tu vois
pas le même style là c'est beaucoup là
comme c'est l'amende en ce moment le
style du rapport sur la compétitivité
c'est plus de l'ordre du roman porno
économique quoi c'est un mélange du
Cristina Angot et Jack Attali le truc
alors l'histoire ça raconte la misère
d'une nommée France dont le péché mignon
et de se faire très régulièrement
prendre en étau entre l'Allemagne et les
pays à bas coût peut-être le seul côté
novateur parce qu'il faut bien avouer
que dans youporn c'est très rare de
trouver la catégorie double pénétration
France in Allemagne
[Applaudissements]
l'auteur a certains Gallois un homme qui
a lui seul résume le déclin français
quand on a été patron deux ADS et qu'on
finisse sa carrière en écrivant une
thèse sous la direction de Jean-Marc
Ayrault
à ce rythme-là dans deux ans il est
animateur à l'UCP
international alors on m'a poussé il
faut en parler d'accord je vais en
parler de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
un fait divers assez anodin un noir
réélu à la tête des USA c'est bon tout
le monde est content il est élu grâce au
vote féminin donc forcément c'était plus
une élection mais un concours de beauté
c'était
et c'est là c'était vite plié quoi entre
une future icône Nespresso et un
mannequin pour séminaire au Novotel
enfin il y avait pas photo
alors pour le coup on connaît la plus
connue de ces électrices elle s'appelle
Sandy oui en Amérique les catastrophes
naturelles font les élections en Europe
c'est l'inverse les élections qui font
les catastrophes naturelles
quel ferveur en Europe pour Obama c'est
vraiment on est vraiment attiré que
parce qu'il nous ignore c'est Obama je
crois que la seule fois où est la
prononcé le mot Europe durant sa
campagne c'est lorsqu'il a fait un
lapsus pour diogrès
alors un journal a fait l'inventaire des
goûts culturels des deux candidats Obama
m Star Trek et les Fugees promenaient
and Star Wars et Roy Orbison
au moins aux USA les parents sont vite
au courant de l'avenir des gamins si le
gosse aime David Lynch et Tchaikovsky
peut oublier la politique
façon qu'est-ce qu'on va retenir
d'élection américaine baraque est
toujours amoureux de Michel et c'est
toujours dire bonjour de son avion c'est
un steward quoi
autre chose à l'international Kim
Jong-Il est vivant il s'appelle psy il
fait de la musique
et il restera à jamais dans l'histoire
comme le père de cette incroyable pas de
danse qui consiste à imiter le
chevauchage d'une prostituée avec les
ans d'un jockey formé par Michou
Gérard Longuet le mi-marso réactionnaire
a adressé un très beau bras d'honneur à
l'idée de repentance algérienne alors
moi je comprends pas cette histoire de
repentance par rapport à l'Algérie
française je veux dire de d'accord ok
enfin on est parti tard de là-bas mais
n'est-ce pas la preuve qu'on y était
attachée
alors je ne dis pas que la France n'est
pas commis d'erreurs en Algérie enfin
bien sûr bien sûr oublier de pomper tout
le pétrole avant les accords d'Évian
quelle connerie
et il faut l'avouer c'est vrai qu'entre
1952 et 1962 les services publics
français ont eu une manière un peu
virile de demander aux Algériens
certains renseignements sur des amis
éventuels qui auraient pu être mêlés à
des affaires de feux d'artifice illégaux
la France ne s'est jamais excusée mais
l'Algérie c'était l'excusé nous avons
envoyé une rue commerciale
[Applaudissements]
sans transition selon Serge Dassault
l'homosexualité est une des raisons de
la décadence de la Grèce c'est vrai il a
trop raison
Platon Socrate Aristote quelle tas de
fumiste
comment admirer des gens qui passaient
leur journée à caresser des concepts
tout en chatouillant des effets
quand même gonflé d'assaut quoi un
industriel de l'armement qui t'explique
que l'homosexualité c'est la fin du
monde
la bombe atomique qui se moque du gaz
moutarde
quelques bonnes nouvelles quand même le
mariage gay est devenu le mariage pour
tous ouf
enfin pouvoir officialiser avec ma mère
[Applaudissements]
le plus dur ça sera d'annoncer à mon
frère que c'est aussi mon fils
une bonne nouvelle pour nos amis SDF 52
morts par jour en France à cause des
accidents domestiques c'est bon arrêtez
de vous plaindre sur ce coup-là vous
êtes à l'abri alors
la belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
alors le gros truc de la semaine
évidemment la conférence de presse de
René Coty
prévu pour durer une heure et demie ça
débordé d'une demi-heure c'est un signe
c'est comme au foot quand on sait pas
marqué dans le temps réglementaire on a
les prolongations
alors rien que son introduction ça a
duré 45 minutes il vous apprennent quoi
Léna
alors après j'ai compris pourquoi ça a
duré si longtemps chirurgie une
introduction ça s'appelle une anesthésie
et là on a eu droit à la péridurale de
l'esprit
malin Hollande malin il a pris son temps
pour bien faire allumer dans le crâne
des journalistes le petit clignotant bon
il est où le buffet et coupe la
Champagne c'est ça
la grande interrogation c'est évidemment
est-ce qu'il va réussir sa conférence de
presse ils sont au courant les journalus
que c'est lui qui a fixé la date et
qu'il a eu six mois pour s'y préparer je
sais pas quoi puis je rappelais que
c'est un énarque quand même la formation
d'un énarque j'ai vu ça coûte 168000
euros par an si à ce tarif là tu arrives
à te faire déstabiliser par une question
deniso Delahousse et qui a un problème
alors l'opposition qui est très déçue
qui est très déçu évidemment vous
attendiez à quoi
ils disent quoi pour vous faire plaisir
moi président enfin je le crois
ou du moins on me le dit mais je ne suis
pas sûr car je n'en ai ni les capacités
ni le talent ni le charisme mais je me
dois d'être dans l'apaisement
parce qu'un président de la République
c'est aussi un apaiseur c'est un
relaxant c'est c'est un homéopathe de la
vie publique
un ostéopathe de la cohésion sociale
de l'industrie française
oui je le dis
est-ce que
oui
je me dois
pour persévérer dans la droite ligne de
manuité transcendante
moi j'aimerais annoncer que l'année
prochaine nous allons sortir du
nucléaire mais aussi de l'hydraulique de
l'éolien du pétrole du compost et même
du soleil
moi je n'oublie pas mes engagements
je le dois aux Français oui au droit de
vote aux étrangers mais par souci
d'équilibre car il faut apaiser et je
suis un herboriste je veux le supprimer
au français comme je veux interdire le
mariage hétérosexuel sauf entre cousin
frère
et les personnes qui ont leur
quarantaine unité de cotisation
j'annonce aussi un nouveau paquet fiscal
qui portera la TVA 80% la CG à 90 et on
impose sur le revenu à 145 alors tout ça
je en gros en gros je peux bien sûr je
parle pas des velléités de d'imitateur
encore que Canteloup doit trembler mais
avec cet humour typiquement hollandais
tu vois moi je vois les sondages mais un
sondage ne fait pas le printemps encore
moins les Galeries Lafayette ou les
Samaritaine
[Applaudissements]
et les journalistes tellement shootés
qui lui ont trouvé des accents
churchilliens
ah bon
il a dit quoi qu'il fallait stocker du
riz et de la farine en vue des futurs
bombardements de la wehrma
sortir les soldats d'Afghanistan les
concentrer sur la rive gauche du Rhin si
seulement seulement non parce que ça
c'est un serment il commence à me pomper
les cheveux quoi
ce qu'on devrait faire ce qu'on devrait
pas faire quoi c'est bon quoi nous on
est là comme des cons aplati devant
cette fascination pour l'industrie
allemande ça va quoi ça va quoi quand
même pas recevoir des leçons de c'est
plus qu'en Birkenstock qui sont fait
défoncer par des chartes fabrication
soviétiques
en face bon la droite qui couine ouais
ouais mais si Hollande a vu le courage
de Schroder ça va quoi il a fallu six
mois Hollande pour établir la TVA quand
Sarko a mis 10 ans à pigé que ça serait
peut-être une idée de supprimer les 35
heures
il me fait penser à parking Sonia
épileptique l'illusion de l'énergie dans
la certitude du surplace
alors quelqu'un y aller de son couplet
forcément je pense tout le monde l'avait
appelé selon François Bayrou Hollande a
été à la hauteur de la fonction
qu'est-ce qu'il y connaît
l'entendre parler de la fonction
présidentielle on dirait un puceau qui a
pondu une thèse sur le point G
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment dans ce contexte c'est
normal que des artistes émergent
[Musique]
Nicolas
je t'en prie
viens nous sauver la vie
[Musique]
voilà on a trouvé le Bob Dylan de droite
poussi rayotte monégasque il habite à
Monaco le type Monaco au grand repère de
poètes la Butte Montmartre de la
Méditerranée quand tu penses le gamin il
a 16 ans et 16 ans à 16 ans son problème
c'est le taux d'imposition
quoi pour l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur un Français à gagner au loto on
connaîtra pas son nom c'est pas con il
veut rester discret c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde exemple Lagardère Arnaud
la télé belge a fait aéroportage sur lui
quand tu le vois dilapider son pognon on
te dit que 75 % taux d'imposition c'est
un cadeau
je peux dire qu'à côté de Lagardère
Bernard Tapie c'est Marion Monty
en revanche le type il a du flair quoi
se trouver une cagole en Belgique il
faut y aller
le seul Français qui va en Belgique pour
s'appauvrir autant Bernard Arnault Il
s'exil pour payer moins d'impôts lui
c'est pour épouser une belge pour
diminuer ses bénéfices quoi c'est pour
la fille pas très futée pour une
croqueuse de diamant prendre un mec qui
n'a que 50 ans
de patience ça s'appelle de l'amour
ou alors Arnaud tu sais qui doit la
rassurer lui ouais t'inquiète pas j'ai
90 ans mais j'ai toujours fait moins que
mon âge
parlons d'amour ça fait bizarre de vous
voir
sans amour c'est vrai que c'est pas
Eric nolo sans amour c'est un peu comme
Semoun sans Dieudonné quoi on gagne en
compassion ce qu'on perd en rire
parlant de décès médiatique
l'international nous fournit
régulièrement son lot de macchabée
ouverture de la tombe d'Arafat
quelle folie ne jamais décongeler de la
viande halal
après gigot de 7 heures la rafale de
deux ans
tout ça pour voir s'il n'a pas été farci
au plus tonium c'est vrai que l'avantage
s'ils en trouve c'est qu'ils pourront
toujours envoyer la dépouille en Iran
pour qu'il enrichissent leur bombe
je propose des choses voilà c'est ça
faut essayer quoi que ce soit
et d'ailleurs propos il y a une jolie
campagne d'affichage collectif de lutte
contre l'islamophobie qui a été refusé
par la RATP oui s'ils sont très mal pris
il fallait casser les codes rendre se
rendre sympathique quoi tu vois au fond
ce que les gens reprochent un peu aux
musulmans c'est de ne pas avoir assez
d'autodérision c'est ça moi j'avais une
idée de campagne quoi une belle campagne
avec un mouton un barbu dans une
baignoire et le slogan entre nous c'est
une histoire de goût
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr faut peut-être terminer par
quelque chose d'un peu joli et cette
mort jolie je sais pas marionnettiste
accusé de pédophilie
les gens trouvent ça étonnant
franchement quoi un type qui fait rire
des gosses en ayant un bras coincé dans
le cul d'un ours en peluche
[Applaudissements]
le glauque dans toute sa splendeur alors
évidemment est-ce qu'il y a une bonne
nouvelle cette semaine
il y a eu la journée de la gentillesse
je sais pas moi je comprends pas trop
j'en ai de la gentillesse je pensais
qu'on avait déjà eu c'est la journée de
la femme là on a donné un jour de
mais alors pas belle la vie
soir super
merci alors cette semaine politique ça
fait vraiment longtemps que BFM n'a pas
diffusé une aussi bonne série
c'est émouvant ce qui se passe à l'UMP
franchement dans ce parti obsédé par la
viennoiserie sous Ramadan voir débarquer
le printemps arabe à l'UMP
après le coup du Sirocco le coût de la
coco
alors qui a gagné c'est un problème
d'image c'est un problème d'image quand
tu vois la tronche de Copé même sans
scrutin tu doutes qu'il a triché
alors que Fillon avec ou sans scrutin tu
es sûr qu'il a perdu
bon celui qui moi me déçoit vraiment
c'est Copé je veux dire avant de faire
Pucci c'est la petite dû faire un stage
en Corée du Nord ou en Syrie pour un
type qui se fait de la droite des
complexer quel déception franchement
fallait un petit coup d'État apparu un
petit truc à la chinoise
arrêtez à l'heure du laitier le [ __ ]
en caleçon rayé chaussettes à pois
devant une cour martiale neutre Balkany
procureur Morano juge Copé pour avocat
sous la surveillance du personnel neutre
takedin
alors on diffuse tout ça évidemment on
diffuse sur le site de l'UMP
autocritique publique de Fillon les
rizières à betterave de la Sarthe alors
oui je sais que c'est un peu violent
mais au moins ça a de la gueule quoi
c'est quand même d'un autre niveau que
les luttes internes au PS enfin Ops
comme Ségolène au bout de deux jours et
lâche l'affaire c'est une tristesse tu
as la lutte Aubry royale à côté de
copefiant c'est comme comparer un
magasin bio un abattoir sans
étourdissement
il y a de la virilité chez vous c'est ça
qui est bien tu vois non moi franchement
je trouve que la guerre de l'UMP ça
donne une image déplorable du PS
je voudrais pas être défendu par des
hommes qui sont pas passionnés à mort
parce qu'ils font
quand on aime les trucs virés on prend
pas sa carte Ops une évidence toute
façon il suffit de lire le programme
mariage pour tous la parité la
protection des hamsters en Alsace c'est
qui qui a répondu le programme Marc Levy
façon le vrai drame de cette histoire
c'est que dans le fond les deux ils
s'aiment je suis sûr que s'il ouvrait un
compte sur Meetic pour tout ce qui
partage entre eux ça ferait pas tilt
mais voir crack boum u quoi tu vois le
je vois bien la petite annonce
braquemart obséquieux cherche notable
tes œufs pour passion dévorante
rapport actif passif apprécié
vous me direz en même temps à la France
la France mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout
de la France c'est bon quoi elle a vécu
elle vivra c'est pas quand on voit le
sujet économique majeur soit vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure c'était mital
quoi les gars qui tape sur la tôle
et Montebourg qui va sauver ça bah
voyons c'est t'imagines la rencontre
entre Montebourg et mital c'est vous le
mec à la marinière et au mixeur alors
moi je veux pas parler au type du
téléachat
Montebourg qui dit qu'il va nationaliser
l'autre il éclate de rire en voyant
Captain Iglo s'énerver mais non voyons
Arnaud quand je veux dire moi je sais
pourquoi les nationalistes c'est pour
récupérer Pulvar c'est évident
mais ouais moi aussi je vais te prouver
que je peux faire des achats sanctuaires
quoi tu verras moi je suis national ça y
est quoi je suis un mec quoi je vois la
grappe quoi
c'est beaucoup dans le silence que je
fais c'est
la prochaine étape c'est quoi c'est
nationaliser les Inrocks
après mon bourre mital a été reçu à
l'Élysée ah c'est sûr qu'en face de René
Coty là à la chemise va se faire dessus
quoi
se faire emmerder par un ferrailleur
avec une tronche de vendeur de rose
[Applaudissements]
surtout quand on voit ce qui te tracasse
le gouvernement en ce moment c'est quoi
c'est les punkshiens qui font des
cabanes sur des tarmacs quand j'achète
l'impression de voir le rassemblement
annuel des sosies de Zaz
[Rires]
ça c'est du sujet quoi ça c'est du sujet
quoi faire des tables rondes avec des
terroristes naturels découvertes
des tables rondes des cagettes retournés
moi le côté SDF des bois sans douche
fixe je sais pas quoi je sais de quoi je
parle une fois je suis sorti avec une
altermondialiste chacun c'est dossiers
bon le seul côté pratique avec une
altermondialiste que pour les mycoses tu
as pas besoin de passer au labo ça se
voit
[Rires]
j'étais obligé de faire une semaine de
thalasso pour m'en remettre alors
pendant ce temps pendant ce temps valser
Taubira black et Mortimer de la
présidente
qui s'excite sur la Corse mais
laissez-les tranquille les Corses dans
un monde où le bruit est un fléau
respecter un peu leur loi du silence
je ferais mieux de lancer une alerte
enlèvement pour retrouver Jean-Marc
Ayrault
moi j'ai lu le truc un immigration
choisie on demande surtout des médecins
et des ingénieurs ça tombe bien quoi
c'est typiquement le genre de métier
qu'ils ont en excès dans les pays du
Sahel
c'est un peu comme si on ouvrait des
quotas de charcutier pour les
ressortissants iraniens
bref faut être réaliste c'est vrai qu'on
peut pas accueillir toute la misère du
monde quoi on a déjà la CGT SOS Racisme
alors l'Europe va mal pas partout il
reste encore
Erasmus pour sauver l'Europe ce très
beau truc là une française avec un nom
espagnol qui se fait enlever par un
Français d'origine marocaine roulant
vers l'Allemagne
heureusement qu'il y a encore des gens
qui se battent pour le marché commun
quoi
après le covoiturage le coffre à turage
alors ok ok bon le type il a quelques
petits problèmes pulsionnels à régler
mais quand même comme moi j'ai vu la
voiture le coffre c'était pas comme
d'une panda
c'est une bonne berline et puis bon le
petit Royal quoi il lui a payé tous les
péages donc quand seigneur tu vois
et la fille un peu plus ingrate quand
même je dois dire j'ai vu l'interview
quand elle est revenue d'Allemagne pour
un séjour d'une semaine et elle a pas
appris un mot quoi
[Rires]
c'est quand même un moment faut être to
give to get quoi
à propos de santé
à Grasse un violeur s'est fait
poignarder par sa victime ça c'est
terrible voilà ce que ça fait faire
l'impasse sur les préliminaires
parlons culture le Portugal ne
participera pas à l'Eurovision faute de
moyens
c'est comme ça moi je regarde pas
[Rires]
et à l'international pareil les
terroristes ne sont plus qu'ils étaient
au Mali alors ce type qui s'est fait
kidnapper je sais pas l'otage qui
demande la mobilisation de la France
contre classique tout en précisant qu'il
est bien traité
il est au courant de ce qui se passe
dans ce pays quoi elle est restée du
coeur qui ouvre lui il est nourri logé
gratos c'est bon quoi démerde-toi
[Applaudissements]
peut-être faudrait-il songer à terminer
par une bonne nouvelle
ce sans-papier qui vient s'annoncer à la
préfecture et qui se fait dénoncer par
une fonctionnaire zélé au flics
même sous les socialistes le service
public reste attaché au devoir de
mémoire
ta belle la vie
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors selon les Mayas dans 11 jours
c'est la fin du monde bon c'est le
calendrier maya tu vois le truc c'est
pas le covadis
qu'on arrive pas à synchroniser avec
iTunes moi je me méfie un peu c'est sur
la perspective de cette fin du monde
pèse tellement qu'on le ressent
terriblement sur l'actualité qui sont
bien mis en berne cette semaine
politiquement bon ça n'en finit plus à
l'Assemblée nationale ce speed dating
entre Copé et Fillon les lovecteurs du
palais Bourmont on attend encore un
signe de détente peut-être la livraison
d'un jacuzzi c'est
pendant que les deux se montrent leurs
photos de vacances il paraîtrait que le
ministre du Budget un compte planqué en
Suisse
enfin un signe de compétence
[Musique]
et qu'il aille le planquer en Grèce quoi
c'est
pour une fois qu'un homme de gauche
s'est placé du fric
bon l'info est de Mediapart moi je me
méfie c'est Médiapart le jean-Marc
Morandini.com du trots
d'autres ministres souffrent beaucoup
cette semaine difficile pour Arnaud
Montebourg
c'est un peu le Dominique de Villepin de
gauche le côté flamboyant sur le côté
lettrés c'est Villepin arrive à écrire
des poèmes Montebourg n'arrive même pas
à torcher une lettre de démission
alors je veux pas le charger quand je
veux dire il va pas bien il s'en remet
pas de sa rupture avec
cette journaliste de très grand talent
dont le souci d'effacement est de pudeur
resteront à jamais gravés dans la
mémoire de Twitter
alors évidemment il nous reste Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui arrive à traiter quand
même le bon président de Louis XVI c'est
vraiment Mélenchon quoi après le bras
arrière exalté des barricades invisibles
on découvre une autre facette de sa
personnalité le fin connaisseur en
meuble ancien régime parce qu'il pensait
sans doute à la commode vu le format du
Régent plutôt que de l'appeler Louis XVI
il aurait été plus inspiré de l'appeler
Castorama premier
qui cette semaine était à Lens pour
inaugurer le Louvre j'ai pleuré trois
jours quand j'ai entendu ça [ __ ] le
Louvre à Lens
pourquoi pas ouvrir des hauts fourneaux
à l'île Saint-Louis
c'est à peu près aussi con que d'exposer
des œufs Fabergé dans un buffet écart
j'imagine déjà l'inauguration tu vois
castoche premier avec un discours truffé
de ses petits jeux de mots minables je
vois la Vénus de Milo et je me dis pas
de bras pas de calais
ce musée ce musée ça peut créer que des
déceptions quand j'entends déjà les
commentaires des ploucs à la sortie ah
c'est dommage ça aurait fait un si beau
bowling
et bon on a le sang de Georges Pompidou
à Metz le Louvre à Lens reste plus qu'à
ouvrir le musée de la marine aux Deux
Alpes
façon culturellement sans Lise il paraît
qu'on peut plus enseigner certaines
matières à l'école j'ai regardé ces
matières en croisade colonisation
sexualité darwinisme dans ces cons que
des matières ou à la fin c'est
l'Occident qui gagne
même les croisades c'est pas facile et
croiser sont partis de Terre Sainte
c'est juste parce qu'ils ont compris
assez vite que Gaza n'avait pas le
potentiel touristique de Deauville
parce que je sache Gazan n'a jamais eu
un pavillon bleu quoi
alors de toute façon il y a des choses
plus graves à la Syrie qui menace
d'utiliser l'arme chimique enfin un
signe d'apaisement
parce que je rappelle que Bachar
el-Assad des médecins enfin je sais pas
vous mais moi je trouve vachement moins
inquiétant de voir un médecin pratiqué
une chimio quand un tir au mortier
j'aimerais pas monter une armée avec les
anciens de la Croix-Rouge quoi c'est ça
c'est déjà fait une fois ça s'appelait
large de Zoé
en plus c'est pas facile d'être en
concurrence avec le conflit
israélo-palestinien elle a Palestine qui
vient d'obtenir le statut des
topservateur vu sa capacité de réaction
on pouvait pas prétendre à autre chose
la Palestine qui balance des roquettes
en Israël c'est un peu comme lâché
Gilbert Montagné devant un jeu de
fléchettes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en plus quand on voit où tombe ici qui
balance enfin on sait jamais s'ils sont
en train d'attaquer ou de chasser le
mérou dans la baie de Haïfa c'est un
truc bien sûr les gens se plaignent
c'est un sujet délicat oui les
Israéliens on voit aussi des missiles
sur Gaza sans blague devrait les envoyer
ou sur les îles Féroé
non les gaz là oui il faut être un peu
cohérent se plaindre d'avoir tout perdu
quand on passe son temps à dire qu'on a
rien
quel mauvaise foi
santé d'après une étude universitaire
portant sur les 20 dernières années le
sperme en France serait de moins bonne
qualité
ouais je sais c'est triste non mais
c'est prouvé quand on voit le mal que
Rachida Dati a eu pour faire un gosse
elle sait pas qui elle perd si elle
était un peu maligne elle aurait dû
demander des tests supplémentaires avec
l'exhumation d'Arafat
émotion Chirac fait ses 80 ans en
Conseil constitutionnel il a pas l'air
si mal franchement à son âge ressemblait
à Jean-Marc Ayrault
lors des nouvelles de Jean-Marc Ayrault
genre je l'ai entendu sur RTL je sais
pas quoi enfin quand on le voit dans les
médias on sait jamais s'il vient nous
dire qu'il supporte bien les soins
palliatifs ou s'il sort à céder le chant
de Noël
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est bien les les médias bougent
beaucoup en France en ce moment il y a
France 3 qui change de grille de
programme ils vont supprimer les
émissions au soir pour de l'info ça va
être quelque chose vu leur réactivité
légendaire on tient la première chaîne
en continu mais en décalé et BFM sous
prozac je sens que ça va donner un
second souffle à la vidéo surveillance
qu'est-ce qui se passe à Rouen il pleut
ouf
et comme c'est bientôt Noël et j'ai eu
cette polémique je crois que ça s'est
déjà terminé d'ailleurs c'est les
écoliers privés du Père Noël alors pas
assez laïque soit disant c'est vrai que
le Père Noël symbolise bien l'Union des
principales religions monéthéistes la
barbe du salafiste la lèvre pédophile de
curé et la générosité du rabbin
[Applaudissements]
après il faut être honnête le si on
décortique un peu le Père Noël et
clairement prokato
des sapins on en trouve pas beaucoup
aryad et puis sans faire dans le
scabreux mais passer par la cheminée
c'est pas très holoca friendly quoi non
non
faut peut-être terminer sur une bonne
nouvelle fait divers Bruxelles un
étudiant se déguise en femme et se fait
violer alors l'école estime qu'il
n'aurait pas dû se déguiser pour ne pas
provoquer certaines populations
violer un mec par homophobie il faut le
faire
alors pas belle la vie
[Musique]
alors dans 6 jours c'est la fin du monde
alors
dernière chronique on s'en fout alors
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être à cause de ça
que soudain Jean-Marc Ayrault s'est
réveillé
c'est un peu toujours comme ça c'est le
syndrome du cancre quoi il se réveille
toujours une semaine avant le conseil de
classe
alors du coup c'est l'explosion
médiatique le plan comme de la dernière
chance avec cette phrase incroyable
c'est minable c'est exilés fiscaux qui
veulent s'enrichir
quelqu'un lui a expliqué le principe de
l'exil fiscal à Jean-Marc croyez quoi
qu'on s'exil en Belgique parce qu'on
rêve d'habiter une petite maison en
brique rouge baigné par l'odeur de bière
et de moules dans un environnement où on
risque à tout moment d'être invité un
rassemblement de tuning ou un mariage
qu'on s'engain
alors
oui c'est c'est vrai on a perdu de par
Dieu c'est vrai on a perdu GG mais
est-ce vraiment un drame avec tous ces
pontages et son cholestérol il
rapportait peut-être en impôts mais
qu'est-ce qui coûtait à la sécu
[Applaudissements]
et si on ajoute à ça ces accidents de
scooter Enfin le gouvernement est au
moins sûr de faire baisser un chiffre
c'est ceux de l'insécurité routière tout
car on aura pris un truc augmenter le
RSA ne pas toucher au livret A grande
nouvelle les pauvres sont capitalistes
c'est livré à 10% de plus pour le RSA ce
qui va faire 47 euros de plus par mois
[ __ ] de rentier
ça va être faite allez hop du mot son de
canard et un bon cubi de crémant
tu es fou non cette année 10 euros de
gain en livret A attends c'est bon quoi
c'est fait tu te rends compte qu'avec
cet argent on aurait pu acheter trois
morpions
parlant de capitalisme
laximital qui s'exprime dans le Figaro
la nationalisation quel bon en arrière
quelques kilos quand même le type est
chouine sur les allées Mitterrand alors
qu'il fait bosser ses ouvriers aux
conditions des années Jaurès alors il
paraît que son entreprise est rentable
heureusement quand même être doué pour
perdre du fric en fabriquant des
produits du 21e siècle au coût du XIXe
la mondialisation ça commence à me j'en
peux plus quoi c'est quoi la
mondialisation c'est le moyen âge avec
du wifi quoi
politique Berlusconi est de retour leur
berlusco il savait le type qui ferait
passer Bernard Tapie pour accompagnant
d'Emmaüs
c'est terrible la lutte des seniors
comme Berlusconi qui prouve au moins une
chose pour bander passer 70 ans il
suffit juste que les filles en ait 50 de
moins
société le prof qui propose aux élèves
d'écrire leur lettre de suicide enfin un
prof réaliste
ce qui serait dégueulasse c'est qu'il
leur demande de cogiter sur comment bien
négocier son salaire dans un monde
ravagé par le plein emploi ou alors
encore pire vous venez de sortir de
l'école dites-nous comment vous allez
acheter votre premier bien immobilier là
tu as vraiment des suicides là c'est
vraiment dégueulasse non je me suis
demandé si Hollande était tombé sur le
sujet qu'est-ce qu'il aurait écrit
moi président
enfin je le crois ou du moins me le dit
mais je n'en suis pas tout à fait sûr
ceci est ma lettre d'adieu enfin c'est
possible
car j'ai décidé d'en finir enfin je le
crois c'est possible inch'Allah
je laisse derrière moi pas grand-chose
non ça j'en suis sûr
si ce n'est la possibilité à des hommes
de faire des bisous devant monsieur le
maire et des gouzi gouzi à des enfants
qui auront acheté pardon adopté enfin je
enfin je le crois
je suis cite sera mon image normal c'est
à dire que je vais me faire un cocktail
explosif un cachet de doliprane écrasé
dans un sirop contre la toux
tous me soutiennent dans ma démarche et
ne me demande qu'une chose que j'emmène
Taubira avec moi
d'ailleurs
parlons de de Miss France Taubira je
sais pas si la transition est idéale
mais enfin on fait avec ce qu'on a le
CRAN alors c'est association de lutte
pour la représentation des Noirs se
plaint que des Françaises d'origine
africaine n'est pas été représentée pour
le concours de Miss France parce qu'à
peu près aussi absurde que si le Klu
Klux Klan se plaignait de l'absence de
blanc dans les clips de rap
d'ailleurs je me suis dit plutôt que se
plaindre de l'absence de noir à Miss
France ils auraient pu se réjouir de
leur absence au Téléthon
d'ailleurs il paraît que les audiences
de Miss France ont été supérieurs au
Téléthon bon c'est normal tu as pas
envie de t'attacher à des gens qui vont
peut-être pas passer l'année
je ne sais pas
c'est une supposition
et il y a eu ce malheureux fait divers
quand même parce que la semaine n'a pas
été très riche mais bref ce type qui
s'évade parce qu'il est maltraité en
prison
pensez rencontrer qui entre les
disciples de Gandhi
on sait que c'était quoi une prison à
Spa avec massage à l'huile de vidange et
cours de stretching anal
peu de saleté parfois ça fait pas de mal
bon
le type complètement flippé ça y est
d'accord d'aller dans une prison mais
s'il y a des types bien c'est comme
demander à être hospitalisé parmi des
gens simples pour être sûr de pas être
déprimé c'est vraiment les exigences à
la con il y aura propos de santé il y
avait un truc qu'on a on a réussi à
guérir du cancer grâce au virus du sida
impressionnant quand même bon je
rappelle que le SIDA est une maladie
grave mais qui contrairement aux rumeurs
ne s'attrape pas par le siège des
toilettes sauf si le type d'avant c'est
pas encore retiré
[Musique]
il y a pas vraiment d'autres points
culminant assis cette semaine le
pousseur du RER qui reconnaît cette
trompée de personnes
c'est vrai c'est moi je demande je
demande donc au type qui était censé se
faire pousser de se dénoncer pour éviter
d'autres victimes
[Rires]
ce documentaire sur lui de finesse alors
assez étonnant j'ai vu c'est à propos
des aventures de Rabbi Jacob l'acteur a
déclaré ce film a fait du bien à moi car
j'avais de bonnes petites idées
antisémites ça m'a décrassé l'âme alors
heureusement qu'il n'a pas enchaîné avec
la Vérité si je mens parce qu'ils
auraient peut-être gardé
ça ça vous fait rire
[Musique]
vous êtes trahi il se marrait pas tout à
l'heure avec moi
terminé sur une bonne nouvelle quand
même valse a décidé de supprimer l'aide
de retour pour les Roms
pour une fois que c'est les Roms qu'on
tape au portefeuille
bravo alors ma belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bientôt Noël dans les maisons les
familles se sont retrouvées dans la
cheminée le feu crépite est sous le
sapins des cadeaux les uns plus gros que
les autres se disputent la faveur des
enfants les yeux des parents sont
remplis de larmes à la vue de ce bonheur
idéal 2012 fut une année phase les
salaires ont augmenté les employeurs
sont obligés d'envoyer des CV aux
salariés d'entreprises concurrentes et
le prix du mètre carré n'a jamais été
aussi proche de celui de la mode de
beurre oui voilà ce qui se passe à peu
près à 7 heures dans n'importe quelle
famille
qatari
[Applaudissements]
alors je précise le Qatar tout le monde
voit ce pays c'est le Mali avec du bol
géologique
en France évidemment les choses sont
moins roses car ce fut une année étrange
enfin jusqu'au 7 mai il y avait un truc
et puis soudain la panne de courant le
placard on a vu une F1 rentrée au stand
et en sortir un Vélib
oui jusqu'au 7 mai 2012 la France
ressemblait à un épileptique coquée
depuis on a droit à un paraplégique sous
morphine
alors que retenir de cette année 2012
une année moderne après avoir cartonné
dans tous les pays du monde enfin le
socialisme débarque en France
alors première mesure le gouvernement
décide de baisser les salaires ça c'est
faut comprendre la seule manière
d'assumer un poste pour lequel on n'est
pas compétent c'est de se rassurer en se
disant qu'on est mal payé
ah bah oui c'est le dialogue mais vous
êtes nul ouais mais on n'est pas cher
bon pour ceux qui en doutaient oui le
changement c'est vraiment maintenant
2012 qui fut bon l'année du choc fiscal
enfin du choc de l'AVC quoi c'est plus
un choc c'est alors moi j'aimerais quand
même défendre un peu ce gouvernement on
reproche à la gauche de pas faire
grand-chose un peu d'honnêteté tu as
quand même le seul gouvernement qui
donne envie à un riche d'aller vivre en
Belgique
à part Dany Boon et Francis home qui
aimerait vivre 6 mois par an coincé
entre roubray et Bruxelles enfin je veux
dire et ne boudons pas notre plaisir
pour une fois qu'un gouvernement de
gauche arrive à expulser des gens qui
payent leur charter tout seul
[Applaudissements]
au fond à l'exil fiscal ça concerne qui
ça concerne les riches qui ne sont pas
sûr d'avoir les capacités de le rester
mais les riches qui partent c'est aussi
des pauvres qui arrivent Bernard Arnault
en Belgique du flot dans un ministère
alors Cécile Duflot tout le monde voit
The Voice
la maîtresse de CP avec un orgasme qui
lui restait coincé dans les cordes
vocales
[Applaudissements]
mais non
je suis pas chiante Jésus c'est juste
que j'ai pas encore atterri quoi
moi ça m'excite très près c'est un peu
le meilleur des deux mondes quoi une
cougar avec une voix d'ado enfin c'est
un truc
mais le retour de la gauche c'est aussi
l'égalité homme-femme qui progresse et
oui désormais en Moselle des ouvriers se
battent pour des hauts fourneaux
c'est aussi les droits qui avancent
bientôt les homosexuels qui pourront se
marier qui pourront adopter à ce
rythme-là dans un an il demanderont
droit de faire l'amour aux femmes non
alors la droite qui très bêtement et
contre quoi au lieu d'être un peu
perfide en proposant en amendement le
mariage pour tous ok mais avec le
divorce pour personne
là on verrait si encore foule dans les
mairies quoi
bref 2012 c'est aussi l'ascenseur social
pour certains Nafissatou qui désormais
dans les palaces hésitera à deux fois
avant d'ouvrir la porte de sa douche à
l'arrivée d'un homme de ménage
[Applaudissements]
la fille ça tout qui qui a la vertu de
rassurer au moins une personne dans le
monde le plombier polonais
au prix où elle pratique la pipe il
risque d'être compétitif encore
longtemps
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
2012 c'est aussi une année sombre pour
la biodiversité on a perdu Eva Joly et
avec elle cette inimitable accent du
sud-ouest norvégien
quand il va parle quelque part dans le
monde un meuble Ikea s'écroule
2012 l'année sport finale de l'Euro de
foot l'Espagne balitalie c'est cool un
milliard de téléspectateurs pour une
fois qu'un conflit entre deux pays du
tiers-monde passionne les foules
2012 c'est aussi l'année des révélations
l'homme politique Manuel Valls mannequin
Téléshopping Arnaud Montebourg
théologienne engagé Véronique Genest
2012 que dire d'autres l'année des
ressources naturelles cette année en
France on a découvert un gisement
insoupçonné le réservoir de voies du
Front National
Front national c'est un peu les gaz de
schiste de la droite c'est à fracturé
c'est dur mais c'est ça peut servir quoi
c'est électorat du Front national qui
aura tempéréé mais bon moi je veux pas
stigmatiser l'électorat du Front
national c'est un électorat très très
créatif puisqu'il est capable d'être
xénophobe tout en habitant la cambrousse
profonde c'est-à-dire un lieu où on
croise un clandestin que lorsqu'il tombe
d'un train d'atterrissage mal fermé
2012 l'année des catastrophes on peut
pas en parler Mohamed Merah à Toulouse
qui pointe les dysfonctionnements de la
police c'est vrai quand tu écoutes les
enregistrements entre la police et
Mohamed la seule information utile à en
tirer c'est que ce n'est pas le raid
qu'on aurait dû lui envoyer mais un prof
de français
et y a-t-il quand même des bonnes
nouvelles en cette année oui oui il y a
une bonne nouvelle le naufrage du Costa
Concordia
pour une fois que ce ne sont pas des
clandestins qui se noient au large d'une
île italienne
alors
ta belle la vie elle est très belle
belle
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu